this morning we're sharing the
remarkable story of a brave young boy
whose diagnosis for a mysterious
condition
is expected to help solve future medical
puzzles researchers recently discovered
a genetic disorder that causes
four-year-old lucario
to produce no antibodies it led to an
immune system so weak that he was
constantly sick
senior medical correspondent dr tara
narulis spoke with luke's family about
their years-long search for answers
tara good morning good morning vlad this
is a condition that had never been seen
before in any medical literature it was
truly a medical mystery
luke was experiencing infection after
infection
and no treatment was working that's when
doctors at the children's hospital of
philadelphia stepped in
with a diagnosis that helped change the
course of his life
today four and a half year old luke
theriot looks
like a normal healthy boy
oh there he is there's my handsome guy
but just a few years ago luke was sick
almost every day
and his health was deteriorating around
seven eight months old he was just tired
he looked different
his eyes were watery and kind of
red underneath he had a really runny
nose
he started to get some red spots on his
face something was different and i
couldn't really explain it
for months he was in and out of the
hospital with no diagnosis
until a test revealed he had no
antibodies and was unable to build a
healthy immune system
if you don't have antibodies it usually
means that you don't have the cells
called b cells that are the factories
for antibodies and as a result you
get infections lots of infections so are
these
two nutrients yeah at the children's
hospital of philadelphia
dr neil romberg and his team of
immunologists ran
every test possible without finding the
cause of luke's sickness
eventually they mapped his entire
genetic sequence
and discovered he had a mutation so rare
it had no name
and had only been seen in mice he had a
mutation in a gene called spy one that
he did not inherit from his mother and
that he did not inherit from his father
this is what we call a de novo mutation
those are extremely suspicious so this
de novo or new mutation
as far as you know had never been seen
anywhere before
it was novel had never been seen before
you ready
spy 1 explained why luke couldn't make b
cells
but it came with another issue there was
a concern
that luke was going to be predisposed to
cancer
a lot of human leukemias have spi-1
mutations in them
and spi-1 is considered therefore a
cancer predisposition gene by many
without a playbook dr romberg offered
the family two options
luke could continue to receive antibody
replacement therapy
and live with the predisposition to
cancer or undergo
a risky bone marrow transplant to reduce
the chance of cancer
and possibly jump start his immunity
what did they tell you were the risks
of a bone marrow transplant to luke that
was a hard conversation i think
it was maybe 10 chance of organ failure
10
mortality rate was a basically it was a
ten to one
odds there were also complications that
maybe would make the quality of his life
worse we really
wrestled with the decision we were
really back and forth i remember
in 2018 when luke was just under two
years old
they made the difficult decision to go
ahead with the transplant
jack their older son was his donor
neither mom michelle
or dad robert were a match
after the transplant and seven weeks in
the hospital
luke's family says his condition
improved
[Music]
they also say it created a lifelong bond
between the brothers
who now share identical dna
who's your best friend jack
jack who's your best friend luki
but the hope that the transplant would
help him produce his own antibodies
which usually occurs in the first year
has not yet worked
one two three for the rest of his life
he may need bi-monthly antibody
infusions and after
three years luke's disease finally has a
name
it is pu1 mutated gamma globulinemia
i've
had some practice saying that word in
the past few years hey guys
while luke's future is uncertain his
doctors believe he will be able to lead
a full life
and he thanks his hero dr romberg
for patients who have diseases who have
not yet been discovered
i think this story is emblematic of how
science can lead the way
we have the capability to really drill
down
on the biology of genetic diseases but
it really does take a partnership
between patients their families doctors
and
scientists since luke's diagnosis they
have found 10 others with this disorder
around the world
and they are now working on a therapy
which gives patients like luke
a new lease on life what are your hopes
for luke for the future
just to be able to lead a full normal
life like any any other kid
and i think that he's even though this
isn't completely
solved he's most of the way there i want
luke
to live cautiously in the ways he needs
to but not
in fear i want him to be adventurous and
daring
and old and not afraid of things so
we're really excited
to let him experience life more
the family says that almost all of
luke's treatments were covered by their
insurance
the work at the hospital was funded by
the jeffrey modell foundation
named after jeffrey modell a young boy
who was born with
and died from a mysterious immune
deficiency his parents established the
non-profit hoping his legacy
will help other children through early
diagnosis treatments and cures
through medical research it's so hard to
see that little body with all the wires
coming out of it and then to know the
parents went to the doctor and there's a
there's no diagnosis so you turn to your
doctor and you say okay how do we fix it
and they say we're not sure
you know my five-year-old daughter saw
this story last night it showed a turn
she said mommy why would god give a
little boy
a disorder like this and you know we
have no answers obviously but
jeffrey modell's family they have a
website where they talk about his story
and they say that jeffrey taught them so
much they taught them that to succeed in
life
you need a wishbone a backbone and a
funny bone
i love that you know and these children
the legacy that they leave
and that is really what they teach us
through dealing with these types
of disorders and their families i think
it's interesting the doctor says it has
to be a partnership
it's not just a partnership these
parents took a big risk they did
absolutely it was there was no playbook
that's what dr what i find remarkable is
that they didn't
they hadn't recognized it in humans
before this and now they've found 10
other people
that have similar conditions that's the
science is remarkable it's amazing and
how many more others right i mean it's
such a huge step
yeah i was going to say that the
community of rare disease
havers is actually quite large in this
country and they're all so isolated the
only thing they have in common is
no one knows what they have that's right
and that's so hard in medicine when you
don't have a diagnosis that's such a
difficult thing to tell a patient
so you know beautiful story beautiful
family things are moving in the right
direction
that's good news thank you tara